feminists doing that's empowering yet
you're relying on creepy disgusting men
who think you are disgusting and trash
to ironically pay your bills which is
probably the most degrading thing in the
entire world whereas actually if you
were in an office it would be a lot less
degrading you could actually have
respect in an office and do not get
offended when you come into the dating
pool and dating world and you are seen
as a low value woman in my eyes you are
in Every Man's eyes you are and uh don't
get offended with people don't want to
marry you don't want you to be their
girlfriend you're going to hit the real
world eventually um it's just a amount
of time and no one with any level of
like a brain would ever respect someone
who does that no it's true like who the
hell who the hell wants to date a sex
worker that is the biggest red flag like
you might as well only fans on a woman's
resumee is like a felony conviction on a
job resume no no no no no no